à
yann chaigne opuz voyage sans passeport
on it you be voici l'église de debra
beyram le seul les 44 sanctuaire de la
ville impériale à avoir conservé ses
peintures originaire de la fin du xviie
siècle est bâti en pierre sèche et j'ai
surmonté d'un motif que s'ils forment
pourtant assez cette extrémité selon la
coutume des jeux l'autruche
les fidèles se retire nous allons
pénétrer and there
voici filmé pour la première fois une
pièce rectangulaire dans les murs sont
entièrement couverts de peinture sur
toile marouflée procès des inconnus dans
la vallée du nil est assez rare ailleurs
sur le mur nord les cinq cavaliers
d'origine égyptienne avec à leur tête
l'empereur fazeli das écrasant de
lorlanges de minuscules ennemis cem de
la vie de jésus à gauche le christ et
ses apôtres sont attablés devant les
traditionnelles galettes dean gerra le
plafond décoré de tête de séraphin aux
yeux étonnés à gauche en dessous de la
scène l'enfer qui se trouvent toujours
peur au dessus de la porte d'entrée des
femmes car les femmes sont paraît-il de
mauvaise augure au dessus de l'entrée
qui mène au saint des saints la
représentation de la sainte trinité sous
la forme de trois milliards en tout
point identique la peinture éthiopienne
ne différencie pas les trois personnes
divines sur le mur chute une madone de
type byzantin et une des figures les
plus populaires saint georges terrassant
brad
quelques manuscrits à présent ce petit
personnage en bas à gauche qui tient la
queue du cheval de saint georges est le
propriétaire du manuscrit
comment l'ange gabriel donne à la
nouvelle à la vierge marie pendant
qu'elle filait lan rayé et le boeuf avec
sa bosse au milieu du dos réchaud plan
forget
le lavement des pieds et un crucifiement
poignant
les jambes du christ ne sont pas croisés
c'est la preuve de l'ancienneté du
manuscrit qui datent de 14 cents cinq
ans est un des très rares manuscrits du
milieu du 15e siècle l'époque de la plus
grande prospérité d'ethiopie et de
l'église
l'empereur encourage le développement
des lettres des arts la peinture et la
miniature sont en plein essor des
richesse incalculable sont accumulées
dans les églises
et
on
quelques années plus tard l'imam mohamed
gras ni même les musulmans à l'assaut de
les copies chrétienne il parvient
jusqu'au coeur même de l'enppi attentes
et ravageant tout sur son passage
l'empereur n'est plus qu'un fugitif
traqué le montagne en montagne la
population et torturé le sang coule à
flots les églises sont brûler saccager
les trésors pillés et avec eux bien des
précieux manuscrits partout ce ne sont
que massacre sauvage neuf hommes sur dix
sont forcés de renier leur foi à la
pointe de l'épée
il est d usage dans la teinture
éthiopienne de faire figurer les bons de
face et les méchants de profil ici les
mauvais musulmans écrase les bons
ethiopie
au moment où le pays est sur le point de
succomber devant la tacc musulmane c'est
alors que débarque un corps de 400
portugais ces hommes commandés par
christophe de gama neveu le vasco de
gama se joindre au défenseur éthiopien
avec leur muller pour leopard et leur
bouclier rond ils livrent bataille aux
infidèles
mohamed et tuer et c'est la délivrance
toute la population prêtre en tête
regarde mohamed en caleçon et en casque
se balancer au bout de la potence de
profils bien entendu son corps va s'en
aller en enfer ce qui est en même temps
le lac tana
il sera mangé par les hippopotames et
crocodiles et les gros poissons
dans la réalité le lac est loin d'être
aussi effrayante si les hippopotames y
sont nombreux ils évitent de se montrer
aux cinéastes
seul un malheureuse iguane s'y promènent
la flottille du lac se compose de ses
canaux et de papyrus leurs fonds n'est
pas imperméable mais il flotte grâce à
leur extrême légèreté
drainant un bassin composé d'environ 60
affluent les limons fécondant du lac
quelle origine volcanique se déverse sur
la campagne environnante l'agriculture
tient une place essentielle les peuples
du yémen qui passait à la mer rouge pour
s'installer sur le haut plateau était
parvenu un très haut degré de
civilisation
il apportait en leurs méthodes de
cultures en terrasse et d'irrigation
le cheval le chameau et la charrue tout
cela était inconnu avant leur passage en
afrique mans
la récolte la plus importante est celle
du tèf c'est une petite graine qui
ressemble un peu aux millet au début des
grandes pluies on le sait mal à voler
puis au labour et la moisson a lieu en
novembre et en décembre a croupi pendant
de longues journées et paysans coupe que
des champs entiers à la possible et il
fonde toute petite gerbe de 10 cm
d'épaisseur
un vrai jeu de patience
esaïe forte utile car le tèf constitue
la base de leur nourriture et dans
toutes les classes de la société
on mange du tèf les éthiopiens on
consomme environ un million de tonnes
par an la farine de tel ne peut servir à
faire du pain mais elle est employée à
fabrication de lignes gerra sorte de
crêpe qui tient lieu de père en même
temps que deux fourchettes d'assiette le
gras et moulu à la main dans chaque
foyer
on trouve au marché ses plaques de fer
ou en terre cuite légèrement concave
d'environ 50 cm de diamètre et c'est là
que je perds cuisons de linde géré à
regarder la pâte faite avec du tèf et de
l'eau lève pendant deux jours chez les
riches le blé remplace parfois lente
on accompagne cette crête d'un ragoût
extrêmement d'épicés dans lequel on cuit
longuement une trentaine d'herbe et de
condiments celle ont les ressources de
chacun on y met viande du ou seulement
des légumes pour atténuer la violence de
cette chose on sait en même temps du
lait caillé et par là dessus en bois de
l'hydromel miel additionnée d'eau et
ferment la voici cuite ont la glisse sur
un plateau rond en vannerie la cuisine
éthiopienne et tu n'es plus épicée du
monde la grande corbeille à pied et à
couvercle que les voir s'est renfermé à
transporter les crêpes d'accumuler qui
seront pas d'un repas une fois le
couvercle enlever c'est une table creuse
ou une poche pour les servir la viande
la sauge sur les cas tous les objets
usuellement de bois sont remplacés par
de la veine
les vêtements consiste essentiellement
en une grande pièce rectangulaire de
voile de coton blanc à bandes de
couleurs aux deux extrémités le chama
nous sommes ici dans une civilisation du
drapé nom du cousu les éthiopiens le
drap de manière très diverse selon les
circonstances et des personnes de vente
ils se présentent une certain l'occasion
apprécier une élégante - des locaux aux
portes de la toge comme jadis les
romains elle n'est attachée par aucun
procédé les femmes pour se livrer à
quelques travail découvrent leurs bras
gauche
les soldats le bras droit souvent au
cache une partie de la figure par un
pays de chama c'est une attitude
fréquente chez les hommes indiquant un
peu de fierté un serviteur dans un
banquet drap son chamade une certaine
passion un plaideur d'une autre le
coteau et travaillé à la main dans
chaque famille et ce sont toujours les
femmes qui le charge de cette besogne
tandis que les hommes disent chaque
année l'ethiopie doit importer du coton
brut car la production est nettement
insuffisante malgré un soleil tu m'as
excellent
opération capitale le choix des oignons
de l'ail de l'échalote et des herbes qui
serviront à la fabrication de la fameuse
souche
non
nous sommes à arras émirati fut célèbre
xvème siècle et au xvième siècle et de
mohamed granié était originaire cette
vieille femme et marchand de feuilles de
café dont on fait une infusion consulte
mais avec du sel les femmes harari ce
porte un costume tout à fait spéciale il
diffère de celui des autres femmes un
pantalon très étroit et de couleurs
vives
quant à ces femmes qui ont une épaule
nue ce sont des gars la scop tous les
jeunes filles pour que leur chevelure
frisée en une infinité de boucles
blondes les femmes marion leurs cheveux
retenus dans un filet et formant
derrière les oreilles comme un gros
magasin
ici du berbère et ou poivrons rouges qui
est le principal des condiments et la
mesure dont on se sert ce bon vieux
était le ménélik et on joue on se bouge
plus
c'est la cohue et s'il y en a qui se
bousculent s'agit de travail d'autres
préfèrent ne rien faire au fond le monde
entier son ensemble
m
où
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec un film de maxime plairait
et le concours de solange péters script
lui cet embryon montage michel la touche
sont clos jean son illustration sonore
dominique pas là dit il